let's stay with that story now um
because yeah elon musk did buy twitter
for 44 billion dollars and joining now
is the co-founder of wikipedia jimmy
wales so let's see what he has to say
about it hi jimmy thanks for talking to
us this afternoon
if you had a spare what 35 billion
pounds would you have bought twitter
um i'm not sure i would have i'm not
really sure what his plans are for it uh
nor how he you know expects
uh to earn a profit there but
it certainly is an interesting thing to
observe for sure yeah so as a business
deal
does it look
attractive where is he going to earn his
money
well i mean i'm afraid
that he's recognized that there's
something uh quite dreadful about
twitter's business model which is that
the more aggressive and sort of hideous
and horrible the site is the more
addictive it is the more outrageous it
is uh the more traffic they get and i
believe he'll probably try to
increase the traffic to twitter by
bringing back donald trump who kept them
in the news every day for four years
more than four years
um and so i i don't think there's going
to be much good for society that's going
to come out of this one well elon musk
begs to differ because he says free
speech is the bedrock of a functioning
democracy and twitter is the digital
town square where matters vital to the
future of humanity are debated
well it's true free speech is a
fundamental and a bedrock of democracy
but free speech uh has to take place in
an environment that's conducive to
sharing ideas and thoughts and
understanding each other not overrun by
trolls and sort of violent uh sort of
useless discourse which is what too much
of twitter is and i think if you take
the view that speech is incredibly
important and shouldn't be made illegal
you also have to take the view that we
need to construct spaces for speech to
flourish in a healthy and positive way
and you don't think he will be able to
do that do you with twitter
well certainly the early indications are
that he's not aiming in the right
direction if you ask me
why though why
well i think if you just sort of take an
absolute free speech approach and say we
wouldn't we wouldn't block anybody
that's clearly not going to work uh
people are can be abusive they can be
there simply to disrupt conversation
it's certainly on all my projects
including wt social wiki and social
where we're trying to build a new type
of social network but at wikipedia and
everywhere else
we
encourage robust and healthy thoughtful
debate but we do that by making sure we
have a safe environment so that people
can really express themselves in a
thoughtful way and basically not
everybody's there to participate in a
positive manner they're there for
whatever reasons trolling uh
state-sponsored sort of propaganda etc
and so unless you control for that uh
you don't really have free speech you
just got a cesspool of noise
in terms of regulation will he run into
problems there if he does try and throw
all the rules out of um
out of out the baby out with the bath
water in terms of that
i mean i think it's not clear i mean in
the u.s of course the first amendment
protects all kinds of speech as well as
should
um whether he runs into trouble in other
parts of the world that's a very good
question uh but i think it's it's also
too early i mean to be fair to elon he's
a very smart guy
um he's you know
i'm sure that he's going to put together
a fantastic team and they're going to
really put some thought into this but i
think the problem may be harder than he
realizes do you think that's how he
operates because you could be forgiven
for thinking that elon musk the richest
man on the on the planet
he says it himself right in 2017 he
tweeted i love twitter so he looks at it
and thinks huh let me buy that and then
you know makes a few jokes of it online
but actually he's looking at it from a
purely business angle and thinks he can
make money out of it
i i assume so i assume so i i it's very
hard for me to know uh it's pretty sad
so
not sure what he's doing but well we're
all along for the ride i suppose do you
think it would be a lot of people are
saying oh twitter will be the next
myspace it'll be obscure in the next you
know couple of years do you think that's
its future or definitely not now
i think it's entirely possible but i i
it's very hard to predict i think it he
could very well double the traffic by
allowing a lot more noise and outrage
and and possibly
causing a lot of damage to democracy in
the thoughtful marketplace of ideas
um or he could potentially find that
people are fed up with that and uh
people start fleeing and looking for
alternatives which is what i hope we'll
see but um well we'll see trump himself
has said that he's not going back on
twitter he's got his own social media
platform hasn't he
trump says a lot of stuff i think i
think when he sees the size of an
audience he can get when his own
platform is basically dead in the water
he'll be back that's my prediction how
how hands-on is elon musk when it comes
to running a company you know a lot of
people say oh we're terrified of what
he's going to make what he's going to do
to the platform but is he really going
to be
hands-on when it comes to twitter
well i think that's a very good question
um certainly one of the reasons twitter
has suffered in my view over the years
that they've had a sort of tradition of
a part-time ceo
and i think that's problematic i mean
elon is known for being extremely
hands-on
certainly at tesla you know reports of
him sleeping on the factory floor trying
to turn things around and meet factory
deadlines so if he chooses to do so he
may really really dig in deep here but
he's got a lot on his plate i mean he's
got tesla he's got the boring company
he's got his space stuff it's hard to
imagine how he could really devote the
kind of uh time himself personally uh to
be hands on which may mean he's just
gonna hire some fantastic people and
that could be very interesting
he's about as eccentric as he is rich
isn't he jimmy thanks a lot for talking
to us